as if stretching a pipeline across the
Baltic Sea weren't difficult enough a
new EU ruling makes it even harder the
Nord Stream 2 pipeline belongs to
Russian energy monolith Gazprom as does
the gas it will transport but a new EU
law bans the pipelines owner from also
supplying the gas with one exception
if Nord Stream 2 had been completed
early this year the law wouldn't apply
it won't be finished until 2020 though
so is Nord Stream 2 over Germany wants
to prevent that the Baltic pipeline will
supply it with 55 billion cubic meters
of natural gas from Russia each year
that's needed to guarantee German
electricity supplies once coal and
nuclear energy have been phased out so
the government here wants its own new
law it states the German end of the
pipeline has already been completed it
merely needs connecting to the undersea
stretch for Berlin the pipeline as such
was completed before the deadline so it
doesn't fall under the new EU
restrictions does that mean the
multi-billion euro Nord Stream 2 project
can be saved
Berlin might not get away with that as
easily as it imagines and because that
sounds very complicated let's bring in
GW SK Brady for more okay first of all
the German Bundestag wanted to discuss
the issue last night but didn't what
happened exactly so they did want to
discuss this issue but Parliament the
sitting was actually called to an end
prematurely and that was due to an
objection by the far-right AFD and they
actually brought into question the
quorum of the German Bundestag so
technically or officially the German
Bundestag only has a quorum when more
than half of MPs are present but of
course when debates are taking place
during the late hours this one was
expected to take place at around 2 a.m.
of course it's difficult to get those
kind of numbers of MPs present so this
isn't anything new something that the
AFD has brought into question on
previous occasions as well so this was
much more to do with a technicality in
in the German parliament as opposed to
the content of this law all right if
Berlin eventually manages to get that
new law through well itself the Khan
promisee that will definitely not lean
for this issue without it's without
further problems of course there is
still a lot of objection particularly
and not only from the EU but also from
the US they've Washington previously
said that Germany would be a hostage to
Russia if this pipeline went ahead and
of course there are also the concerns of
countries like Poland and Ukraine as
well about what potential problems they
might face once this pipeline possibly
comes into action next year okay Brady
they're reporting for us on the Nord
Stream 2 controversy thank you so much